hi my name is Sean and especially with
everything that's going around right now
I'm missing my family quite a lot what
thousand miles apart they live in Hawaii
I live in LA and your boy can't just you
know swim to Hawaii so I had a friend
last and I was like wait why don't we
like talk online and swap our favorite
snacks and just have a fun time so I'm
super excited
you're the love my mom know I love my
grandma can't wait so let's go hi I'm
ginger I'm Sean's mom I live in Hawaii
and next to me is my gorgeous mommy hi
I'm Shirley and Sean is my grandson I
don't know about too much about favorite
snacks because you know at those things
you don't have to watch all these
goodies you have know I'll try my very
best
so bear with me I am a thousands of
miles away from my grandmother and my
mother but it's okay because I'm the
favorite of the family so we good we
gucci right dreaming again well the
first thing I have is Linda or white
chocolate I'm obsessed with white
chocolate I know it's fake chocolate but
that's the best shot that it is meat is
sugary is just delicious in my mouth
it's just high-quality stuff so you
can't go wrong with white chocolate it
may be high-quality because the brand is
an excellent brand but white chocolate
not our favorite boom the thing is my
mom is obsessed with dark chocolate it's
pretty good ah but still not my favorite
so my grandmother is a picky eater she's
so picky do it do it the face she does
John yeah yeah I love love chocolate
chip cookies especially if it's no
cookie no nuts no not I don't care for
cookies and never nuts or ice cream that
have none or candies that have less okay
here we go
[Music]
that's very good what am i favorite
all-time snacks oh boy I just don't like
my popcorn plane my popcorn has to be -
oh just like Sean special it has to be
spiced up and so even though Sean
doesn't have this with him I brought my
own I eat it with something called machi
Kratz popcorn and watch cringe and it
can only be this grand honestly real
tough nor the grand cookies that brand
so my mom loves popcorn so much so much
every time we go to the movie theater
you always have to get an extra large
popcorn because that extra-large refill
is just for her so the next thing I have
y'all know I love some sugar I love
something that's nice and sweet I love
things that are out there cooking crazy
just like myself
um so I got the circus animal cookies is
it good for me no but does it taste good
hell yeah
jeez it's just like childhood for me not
my favorite I know it's very sweet but
the reason why I also love these circus
cookies because it reminds me of a
certain person that is very dear to my
heart I don't know if you guys know this
mom and grandmas i'ma tell you right now
so I met her a couple like 10 years ago
I was very young I went to Virginia with
the family and it was Christmas it was
snowing there's amazing food not only
was there food but there was a show it
was a great show and so as a seven eight
nine year old kid I got to meet my idol
the exotic dancer known as Madame fufu
oh no would you dare show that I'll
don't you side what happened was and
we're stuck inside this hotel room and
we were like doing a little talent show
here comes my grandmother at like 60
something years old and nothing but just
her bra some like silk linen panties
some with like a fake feather boa as
Madame fufu just dancing and giving a
good heart I was just like who is she
and can I please come out more often
grandma Bona the hostess doughnuts we
used to buy it
all the time I mean I couldn't have
enough of these doughnuts because they
loved it so much
these doughnuts have a lot of memory for
me when you said birthday parties for
Shawn and you ought to entertain them so
we would get a stick and put a string on
it and tie the doughnuts to it and see
who would eat the doughnut first from
from this dream there was that I
remember Christmas we would try to see
who could shove the most doughnuts in
their mouth and say a phrase I still do
so much so my favorite snack are Doritos
I love it has multi-purpose to eat it
plain or you put it in but we never had
the readers at all
you know you know all times and when
your mom then was born but I have never
H burritos during burritos rather until
I think it was last year yeah because
but some reason I thought what dude
spicy and now you know what I want to
eat there Eden's as long as it's not
cheese not just not not any other time
but I also say you can have some weird
taste buds because my mom thinks kind of
express orange Ignis spicy and I'm like
it is not you've got the best now come
on be on it mom your choice who's got
the best me I have the best
is there anything grandma or a mom that
you want to tell the audience we love
you yeah we love you very much and hope
we can see you all in person
Thanksgiving so but yeah take care of
yourself and my food better sorry
so it's like great hanging out with you
guys having all three snacks and bring
up all these amazing memories don't
forget to tie go start up for the
comments what is your favorite snack
spend time we do love with everyone and
see ya
[Music]